ted loose skin is a problem for many of
us but we now have a non-invasive
solution
here is lisa brooks from the jazzy
wellness to tell us more
hi lisa so what is an ultrasound skin
lift
the ultrasound is a non-invasive skin
lift
it actually pulls and tightens your skin
it goes down deep to your muscle
to the dermis and it gets your collagen
and
elastin to start rejuvenating and
regenerating and getting all of the
wrinkles and stuff to tighten and pull
into place
so what areas does it treat we can treat
pretty much
um the eyebrows we can do under the eyes
we can do your whole face your decollete
your neck your chin we can also do
different parts of the body as well
we're looking at some of the before and
after pictures here and it is incredible
how long do we do the results last
these results can last up to five years
just depending on how well you take care
of your skin and stay out of the sun
and you know this whole sunscreen and
everything i mean we're looking at
pictures where people look 10 15 years
younger how does this compare to other
procedures out there
well this one first of all it's cost
effective
second of all it's non-invasive so it's
non-surgical
there's no injections there's no
downtime at all on this set either
and so how long how long does it take
for let's say you're having your face
let's say you have your neck done how
long does that take
um the neck probably take about a good
30 minutes to do we want to make sure
that you get all nice and tight
and so describe everyone watching what
does it actually feel like when you're
in there in the chair what does it feel
like
um it feels like a mild tingling um
it's nothing too out of control it's
just like a mild tingling
and what are some of the other
advantages besides you're like 15 years
younger what are some of the other
advantages
the other advantages are well we can
um make you look 15 years younger in an
hour
it's a one-time treatment only again
it's cost-effective
i think that's the key there what you
say right there it's a one-time
treatment you go in there
one and done and you guys just saw the
results uh lisa we appreciate it thank
you so much for joining us today
thank you and you guys always have a
special the jazzy wellness first off is
located at 900
south valley view suite 100 find them
online at thejazzywellness.com
and take advantage of this special deal
first 10 callers receive
40 percent off non-surgical facelift
mercedes